it's all a big conspiracy it's not a  conspiracy they told us at the world  economic Forum they literally said in  Davos if they were to create some kind  of Central Bank digital currency they  would need to implement a Bill of Rights  to ensure that our rights are not  impinged on just because of the  tyrannical nature of this type of  technology that concerns me it concerns  me because during the lockdowns they  didn't abide by the Nuremberg code which  meant you weren't allowed to force  people to put foreign substances inside  their bodies so why would they abide by  some Bill of Rights which they created  to protect themselves